didn't here messing with me but get my
[__] together of course I'm going to get
my [__] together eventually you'll get
your [__] together yeah I'm getting I'm
getting it together right now hi
everybody yeah we've been s we've been
sitting here for like 10 or 15 minutes
and it's like he still hasn't got it
yeah I forgot to go in there he forgot
to go in there he's coming in yeah on
his tablet all right so we're going to
do a review of a a movie called shudder
Island all right and this thing was a
[__] Masterpiece I love this I really
liked this movie a lot I had never seen
it for some reason I don't know how I
never got around to Leonardo DiCaprio
Allstar [__] film [__] it had
who's in this thing Mark Ruffalo was in
it Ruffalo is in he does a great job Ben
Kingsley is in kley Max vow is in Max
von is in it from Sil of the Lambs you
know would you [__] me I'd [__] yeah the
dude yeah oh was she a great big fat
person well she a great he's in it he
does he does a really good job on it and
this this is a period piece taking place
it looks like in the 40s or 50s I 1954
is okay yeah they say that look at po
she now the
show she goes over after the rapping
paper and it's about a Cop who goes to
this island where they have a an insane
asylum on it for the criminal for the
criminally insane and it's owned by the
government it's Federal property and
he's going in there investigating The
Disappearance of a girl one of the
patients yeah now if you ever seen a
movie called Midnight Alle what's
midnight nightmare alley it kind of
reminds me of nightmare alley there's a
lot of twists and turns to it a lot of
Mind [__] in this movie but it's it's
easy to follow it's
not it's just a really good flick real
good I'd like to own it will you stop it
Pokey just tear up paper
yeah she go no no stop tearing it up
Pokey she's she's like okay well at
least someone's paying attention to me
now so I don't have to make she just
wanted attention yeah that's all it is
cuz as soon as we start talking to the
camera she's like no she's like no can't
okay she's going to go in there and do
it again she's going to go but I'm
having a good time I'll punish you poor
poor pooki stay down be quiet she's like
no I can't do that she's looking to be
like okay she's like I'll wait so you're
not looking at I'll do it again yeah
yeah she's such a brat Danny says this
film's proof that uh Martin scorsi can
do horror films and be successful at it
in my opinion yeah yeah here's the thing
like I've I feel like I've seen most of
Martin scores movies right and for
whatever reason this came out in
2010 and I just kept I didn't see it in
the theater and then I just kept seeing
it it's like man I got to get around to
seeing that one of these days but I just
like never did because I kept seeing
like people recommending it and it's
like oh it's so good and it's kind of
like a horror movie and all this other
kind of stuff and I was just like I just
never got around to it so then like
Saturday night I guess it was Saturday
night and I was like scrolling through I
guess it was Amazon Prime and it was on
there and I said you know what I'm
really in the mood to finally pull the
trigger on that and like watch that
movie I said it's but because I told Tom
I said it's between this and momento
because I've been wanting to show him
momento also Christopher Nolan's momento
which maybe we'll do eventually but he's
like I kind of want to watch shudder
Island like the Martin scor has he one
he hadn't seen it either I've never seen
this the first time I've seen it I was
impressed I mean I'm 10 it's real good
I'm 10 or 15 minutes into it I didn't
realize it was s sayi I'm 10 15 minutes
into I goes this movie's great yeah he
immediately got sucked right in like you
can tell if Tom likes a movie or not
because it's like he'll just P he'll put
down his tablet yeah and just watch it
yeah cuz normally if he's like doesn't
really give a [__] he'll keep he'll keep
picking his tablet up and like talking
to people on Facebook and [__] like that
but it's like this one he didn't really
do that he it's one the actress the
story and the tone and the setting it's
kind of like taking place in the if you
if you like video games like Batman it's
kind of taking place in a place kind of
like Arkham with Arkham asy kind of like
that this creepy place on this island
there's no way off he's doing this
investigation he's kind of like an old
uh [__] uh uh old uh like a private
eye you know it's kind of like one of
those kind of FS he's not a private eye
though he's a he's a he's a federal
Marshal Federal Marshal but it kind of
had that private eye feeling to it you
know like yeah you know this the way
this their lingo and looking the acting
was good the storytelling's good just
the edit everything everything about
this movie is a masterpiece if you like
this movie if you if you have seen this
movie and like it I recommend nightmare
alley the new one the gadel Toro one
yeah it's I kind want to see the
original too that was also based on a
novel so was this actually also a period
piece but similar equality and it's
about a guy that joins the Carney a
murderer who joins the Carney Carnival
and great he gains all these skills on
how to be a psychic but he's a fake
psychic and he's able to con people then
he runs into a psychiatrist that do the
same thing they con people and they're
trying to get money and power and he
gets tied up with a billionaire who's a
damn murderer and [__] it's that's a
wild flicks kind of like this one so if
you have if you like this movie see the
new midnight alley gamer [__] great
you'll love it yeah we reviewed it a
while back cuz we saw it in the theater
tonally a tonally similar movie also a
period piece taking place in a Great
Depression yeah this movie here this is
based on a novel hey I'm taking the toys
from you the Abus it you've abused it
now she's running you AB she's like oh
I'm in trouble yeah yeah put that in the
closet or something put it right here
all right cuz then that then she'll y
Christmas wrapping paper yeah I forgot
to put it away so she's like over there
[__] with it right um so yeah so the
novel this was based on came out in 2003
and the guy that wrote it his name is
Dennis leaine now that guy also wrote
the novels that Gone Baby Gone was based
on and Mystic River which I think we've
probably reviewed both of those at some
point but yeah so that guy wrote that
this book too and um to talk about this
movie We're G to have to like spoil the
big twist but I feel like it's 13 years
14 years old at this point so I kind of
feel like if you haveen seen it you
don't know what the twist is then if
you've never seen this movie and you
want to see it I'd probably check out
now because this has got some twists in
it and this is a fantastic epic
flick and I hate to ruin it well the
thing about it like like I said may we
just be vague I don't know it's well
like it's too hard to talk about it like
talk about its themes if you can't spoil
it you know what I mean it's kind of one
of those things we're going to give you
time now you can always come back and
watch this show later Now's the Time you
want to check out Danny said even if you
know the twist in this film it's still
rewatchable in my opinion the thing
about it was that even though I hadn't
seen it like I said I don't know how I
didn't see it in all this time but I
finally got around to it um but even
though I didn't see it I was pretty sure
I remembered that I had read about it
somewhere so I knew what the twist was
you know what I'm saying so I had kind
of Forgotten but then when I was
watching it I was like oh I think I
remember like reading something about
this and I what the twist is but like
you said it doesn't really
affect your enjoyment of it I kind of I
thought this was cool because it seems a
little bit I don't know maybe I'm just
like talking out my ass but it seems a
little bit different than a lot of scors
say's other films because I feel like he
went just
unabashedly genre and he's just like I'm
gonna make like a neon Noir that's kind
of like a Hitchcock film um he said that
he was kind of thinking too about uh Val
luton's films like from the 40s like I
walked with a zombie and stuff like that
and he wanted to make it like that so it
uses a lot of the tropes of an old Noir
film
whereas it's kind of
like not
entirely it's it's it's kind of almost
more like subjective like they're trying
to show things objectively from the main
character's point of view rather than
everything like making narrative sense
I'm not saying there's plot holes and
stuff but I'm just saying that it's
meant to be because of the twist it's
meant to be not
entirely realistic and he shot it in
that way as well like everything looks
sort of hyper realistic or a little bit
slightly surreal but dud crazy but in a
way that doesn't yeah it's almost kind
of like it's trying to put the audience
in the shoes of the main character
character who is not entirely seen let's
put it that way but not for not without
reason though yeah he went through some
[__] here all our reg are saying they
all know it and everything that's what I
mean I think most people know what the
twist is in Shuter Island it's not that
unusual and and this came out like a few
years after a bunch of other movies that
had a bunch of twists like momento and
six cents and all that kind of stuff so
turns out that the detective who's going
to this island to investigate
this missing girl turns out he's not a
detective he's a patient he's just
tripping all right Heath he's crazy and
and he's a patient at that hospital that
that's one of the main things he's not a
detective at all actually he us he used
to be he used but he's not he's a
patient he's a patient because his wife
murdered their three kids drowned him to
death and then he killed the wife and
they locked him up in the asan isum and
it wasn't just that it was the fact that
he had he felt responsible for her
killing the kids cuz he didn't he didn't
get her help because yeah because she
was clearly very mentally ill she had
burned their apartment down yeah and he
didn't want to face the fact that maybe
she needed help or she was maybe well
she was pretty yeah you know dude's
going to [__] he oh you're fine you'll
be fine we'll just move to this house
but then she ends up like killing all
their kids and almost kind of like
killed her to like put her out of her
misery yeah but that's really the twist
people are saying twist is only a small
part of the movie people who have seen
the twist watched against it's better
knowing the twist to yeah because you
can pick up all the clues and stuff like
I was watching a couple of like
breakdowns of it where they were
pointing out they're like really if
you're paying attention The Twist is not
really a Twist which in a way is kind of
the best kind of twist because you don't
just want a Twist that comes like out of
[__] left field and didn't have
anything to do with [__] I see coming in
the thing I didn't see it coming well I
only did because I thought that I
remembered that I read something about
it when they started telling him he was
crazy I thought they were playing a game
with him to try to get him out of there
because I thought it was a CIA front
like he said mind control with the Nazis
right that's what he thought he was
that's what what he thought he was
dealing with but see I like dealing with
project Nazi thing like that they left
it ambiguous enough where that might be
a where that's still a possibility I
don't think that that's what is
happening but you could read it like
that if you wanted to you know what I
mean yeah it probably go either way so
you have U an element of um Total Recall
with Arnold Schwarzenegger in it that's
what I was thinking that it's got that
in it too it's a [__] awesome flick I
want to own it it's it's a masterpiece
the acting is [__] topnotch Kingsley
is the [__] in this all kingsley's been
in some real [__] turds he has but he
he kind of reminds me of Donald Pleasant
he never phones the [__] in he actually
does his job yeah he'll take the [__] to
and in this one man he is [__] great
in it everybody's great in it maxm side
out's great in
it um
[__] r r Mark R's good good in it
[__] um oh [__] what's his name the
[__] the star of the damn show I
forgot Leonardo DEA Leonardo yeah yeah
[__] dicapro this is
probably so far my favorite work of of
deca real and I [__] loved his work
in Romeo and Juliet yeah was saying how
much he likes Romeo and Juliet yeah
[__] that's a I I could watch that
movie over and over the soundtrack is
awesome you [__] R now I have not seen
blood diamonds yet and people say that
he's real good in that too oh that was
yeah that was good I saw I want to see
blood diamond it's been a while I saw it
on an airplane like when it first came
out repl a South African mercenary yeah
yeah and it's based on a real character
yeah so I want to see that one too you
probably really like that I he really
this this movie [__] impressed me man
and and tonally and quality-wise it was
like gam del Toro's um nightmare alley
that movie we saw that in the theater
and it had me riveted Mind Games in that
movie that is really should me you know
far as Tom Ross's mustsee
recommendations for for life to give you
life
skills nightmare alley yeah well like I
said you can learn some [__] from that
movie
yeah Leslie said The Machinist 2004 was
first that's another movie that I've
been wanting to show Tom because I
really really like yeah oh that's great
too but there I feel like for a while
there and this was maybe like kind of
late to the party as far as that goes
but there was kind of a
whole small subg genre of films that
kind of came out in the 2000s like late
'90s and 2000s that had like sort of a
Twist like that where it's like oh it
was all a dream or it was all this kind
of reminded me a little bit too slightly
of Jacob's Ladder which actually came
out in 1990 which you know the twist in
that was that he was dying on the
Vietnam Battlefield the whole time this
was 2010 okay yeah it was back when
Hollywood still made good movies
occasionally this this [__] is [__]
a great fck like I said that Del Toro
film was recent and nobody ever even
talked about was just a couple years ago
C and it was great I'm pretty sure we
could watch it again because I think
it's on streaming for free yeah I want
to I want to own it yeah I want to own
nightmare alley and I want to own this
one
for my own personal collection I'm glad
you liked this one as much as you did
because like I said I had been wanting
to see this for a long time and I just
never got around to it for whatever
reason even though it sounded totally
like right you know something that I
would absolutely want to watch but yeah
so I didn't know i' be a DiCaprio fan I
mean I liked I like the only thing I
knew him from really was was Romeo and
Juliet I never saw a
Titanic Titanic was okay never saw it I
mean he was still pretty young but I
mean's he's great this yeah he became
like a really like a lot of people are
coming yeah blood gamond is great say um
also The Departed yeah that was also
great the Revenant yeah I haven't seen
that one that was one I missed yeah I
got to see more of DiCaprio's flicks man
I this I got a lot of respect for him on
the back of this movie he was a kid when
he did Romeo and Juliet yeah and uh
Clare Dan was in that she was so [__]
cute Dam that was like a baby CLA D mhm
um now she did a good movie that nobody
knows about called broken down palaces
it was broke down pal pal yeah about two
girls that were smuggling drugs into
Thailand and they get busted and they
end up in these prisons they they were
broken down palaces it's based on a real
case I own it on it only came out on
DVD but that that's a good flick too it
was CLA Dan and what was the other
girl do you remember um [__] now I can't
I can't remember it was chicks from the
9s yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good it's a good movie okay Z said uh
Tom's seen The Aviator right I'm sure
Jenny has yeah I have seen The Aviator
seen I've seen it a couple it was pretty
good yeah Z said Jenny's seen everything
pretty good I haven't seen everything
there's a lot of movies I haven't seen
but I have seen a lot of movies yeah I
try to keep up with stuff yeah a is
pretty good I'm I'm a fan of Howard
Hughes yeah so real Howard that's why I
knew that yeah um but yeah so so here's
the thing this movie like I said it's
very much
like this seemed to get like pretty
positive reviews when it came out and it
actually made a lot of money I think
this is still his second highest
grossing film ever really yeah um i'
never even heard of it yeah um so it is
like it it kind of got that I think some
critics didn't like it because and it
doesn't get talked about as much maybe
like nowadays as some of his other films
did I think it was because it was just
so
unapologetically a genre film he was
trying to make something that was like a
throwback like a period to like a Noir
yeah like a Noir right so he used like a
lot of the tropes from that and he very
much leaned into the idea that you were
making everything um like an artifice
like even from the first scene of the
movie where you know Leonardo DiCaprio's
character his name is Teddy sort of
that's not actually his real name but
you know what I mean so we'll just call
him Teddy um is coming to shudder Island
on the fairy
boat um everything looks like the water
and stuff like that behind looks
slightly slightly fake in a way that
you're kind of like watching it going
that kind of looks fake but not exactly
but then like you don't really know it's
almost kind of like meta in that way
where he's like everything looks sort of
like artificial I thought it looked
great and the reason that it looks
slightly artificial but not in a way
that draws attention to itself is
because you're seeing everything from
his perspective and his perspective is a
little bit wrong warped yeah I to me
when they show the island and the things
that happen to the island it's like some
kind of Arkham Asylum in the Batman
video games it's very Gothic looking and
dark and stormy always and water because
A hurricane's coming yeah and it's it's
just this huge damn Fortress Civil War
Fortress Is where they're holding all
these mental patients and they got
vehicles on the island and you get a
real kind of Trapped feeling kind of
like that witch flick the the Legacy
where you know you can't get away from
the house cuz all roads lead back to the
house it's kind of like that kind of
feeling um I just just can't say enough
about the movie I [__] I thought it
was great one of the best movies I've
seen and like I said The more you think
about it and the more like once you know
what the twist is that this is all all
the stuff about him being a US Marshall
and him coming there like looking for
this missing woman and the thing about
his wife dying in a fire and all that
stuff like after you find out that none
of that is true and really they're just
doing this elaborate role play like
because they think that that's going to
like help him get better so they're just
kind of like letting him they're like
indulging him I guess yeah like they're
just all going along with it um once you
know that and you go back and watch it
um cuz I was watching like some uh some
breakdowns of it where they kind of went
back and they looked at all the scenes
they're like once you know that he's not
really who he thinks he is and that
everybody on the island like all the
other patients and the doctors and
everything like that are just playing
along with his delusion like a lot lot
of the scenes make a lot more sense yeah
I want to see it again you know what I
mean yeah I want to see it again and all
the stuff too about um cuz even like I
said from the first scene where he's on
the boat and he's talking about like how
seasick he is and all that other kind of
stuff it's because he has an aversion to
water because of his wife drowning yeah
the kids and it's like but he can't
confess that to him so he keeps saying
she died in a fire she died in a fire
but she didn't you know he shot her so
it's just it's just kind of like he
can't deal with it so he's constructed
this elaborate fiction and it's just
like I don't know like the more you
think about it it's just really well
constructed the way that all these
scenes kind of like I said if you're
paying attention you could probably
figure out I'm watching the movie and
within 10 minutes I'm drawing in I'm
going this is a [__] Masterpiece
movie I had no idea it was it was Martin
scor now start making more sense like I
said it's a little unusual for his for
his type of movie yeah he doesn't make
anything bad no he he knows how to I've
never seen anything bad he knows how to
bring a bring an audience into the story
and it has a lot of horror aspects to it
it's good yeah big time that's what I I
kind of feel like this is almost I don't
know if I'd call it a straight horror
movie but
almost you could maybe call it a
psychological horror yes because look if
Jacob's Ladder is a horror movie then
this is probably a horror movie too so
maybe it is an actual horror it had
almost a kubrickian feel to it it almost
felt like a kubric movie did it did a
little bit almost felt almost felt like
eyes wide [__] kind of yeah the the tone
and I want I want to see that again I
haven't seen that in a long time eyes
watch we can watch that tonight if you
want maybe don't we have it uh I got it
I think I thought we had it I think I
might have it yeah haven't seen in a
long time Z said I'm a huge DiCaprio
Fanboy he's been in so many good movies
he really has who said that Zan said I
wanted to hate him cuz he was a pretty
boy but his acting skills made me love
him I kind of feel like a lot of I
didn't take him serious well yeah well
and a lot of I was watching another
review of this movie like earlier and he
said the exact same thing he's like when
Leonardo decaprio first came on the
scene and was you know he was in Titanic
and blah we blah and it's like all the
girls loved him and it's just kind of
like oh my God like [__] that dude and
everything like that but he's
really it doesn't happen much usually
can get these kind of hot young actors
and stuff and they don't you know do
anything they're not that great or
whatever but he is like actually in some
great [__] [__] yeah that if you like uh
Romeo and Juliet with with DiCaprio in
it I went and did my research I so much
of a fan of that movie all the innuendos
in that version of the movie are true
all in other words all the innuendos
about drugs and homosexuality and all
that is all in the original and people
have noticed those for hundreds of years
yeah that's all from the play they they
didn't make anything up no why do you
think they've it's easy to adapt for
modern audiences all that [__] was going
on back then if Mercurio Mercurio
probably was in love with Romeo and gave
his life for him and then cursed him
after his mortal wound you know pox on
your your both your houses that that's
you know that's but that's probably when
you read the dialogue even in the
context of that time because he was
saying he was in he his love could never
be
achieved he was
gay and he was in love with uh Romeo
Tammy says Inception is another a great
Leo movie I agree that is a great
[__] movie you'd probably like that
too that's that's a mind [__] Inception
yeah I don't think plus it has Tom Hardy
yeah I don't think you've seen it either
that anything with Tom Hardy man that
movie is great you should probably see I
haven't seen Tom Hardy in a bad movie no
I don't think I have either now that I'm
thinking about it that [__]
right there man he's a great British
actor and uh he delivers on screen I
like I'm a big fan of Hardy and great
ass does he yeah that's right it's not
the ass it's the back arch it's the back
arch it's the back arch that makes it a
great ass yeah yeah but you know what I
mean Leslie said can see uh a lot of
going on from the classic folk folkore
the Wicker man I thought that too like
because the whole story of the wickerman
the original one not the Nicholas Cage
one um is they draw the cop to the
island under false pretenses because
there's a missing girl but she turns out
not to be missing which is kind of the
same thing here so I was actually
thinking about oh kind of like the
Wicker man I mean in other ways this
movie isn't anything like the wickerman
but like that plot setup is kind of like
the wickerman yeah Zan don't bother
sending me uh uh uh I got the steel book
of he's got steel book of I got the
deluxe Ste you guys don't understand he
[__] loves I love that movie that
movie yeah he loves that movie I watch
that over and over again we've seen it
multiple times he loves that movie so
[__] and I love the soundtrack yeah
yeah yeah I even put songs from the
soundtrack like on my phone so he could
listen to it in the
car the gayest song of all times is on
there is one of my favorite songs
[__] Angel by Gavin Friday Gavin
Friday yeah he loves that [__] song
and comes on I'm like oh it's time for
the gay party it's me and Zach up in the
[__] penous J with a
camera yeah we're going to have a whole
[__] serving tray of [__] luds and
cocaine and [__] it's going to be the
gayest party of all [__] time just
snort up every time that talk that's
right yeah uh yeah Sebastian's also
saying Wolf of Wall Street yeah that's
another good one uh Killers uh killers
of the flower Moon yeah that's the one
that just came out also has Leo in it
great film yeah and I got to I got to
see [__] blood diamond yeah I got
that [__]
rifle you should probably the blood
diamond carbine the AR15 I got but I
haven't seen the movie yet I just seen
the rifle yeah that I I love the xm177
or the K15 I built one I got a [__]
new A1 carry handle upper coming it'll
be here tomorrow so I can get rid of
that detachable carry handle you got
guys know what I'm talking about finally
go over the thing is you can't get the
original colors the original colors were
gray phosphate kind of gray and and and
it was kind of a light black and when I
was in the Army the the a the uh M16
A2 and the A1 issues were not uniform
colors the upper and the lower and they
they're being done by different comp
companies and the magazines were kind of
silver but you can't get those colors
anymore everything's black now
unfortunately that's why they're spray
painting the when they do a blood
diamond carbine reproduction they're
spray spray painting at tiger stripe
yeah Z said uh I loved John leg with in
Romeo and Juliet yeah he actually I
really like John lamo generally like
he's always fun in everything that he's
in he was one of he was in um what was
the georgo it was um was it Land of the
Dead yeah one of the georgo zombie
movies and the the differences between
the Capulet and the uh [__]
monu's is uh was ethnic even back in
those days it was more of a Spanish
family versus more of kind of like a
French type family that's why they
weren't inter Maran you know there's so
what you see in that movie is is
accurate to the
original those two families weren't
supposed to be mixing that's why Romeo
and Juliet were not supposed to be
together like I said that's why
Shakespeare's plays are Timeless because
you can adapt them to any time period um
and it totally works because if you know
um the euphemisms and [__] they were
using it's not that different from
modern day so you can update it like
easily so technically of the age of the
in Shakespeare's time that was an
interracial Romance they that's what
they' have considered
it they're also talking about Gangs of
New York yeah I really like I think I I
think I saw that in the theater haven't
seen a long time I remember it being a
great movie yeah I liked it a lot yeah
that cores M yeah okay yeah uh CLA Danes
was great straw dog says CLA Dan was
great in U-turn from 1996 with Shawn
Penn and Nick Noti directed by Oliver
Stone I haven't seen that in a long time
I totally forgot about that she was so
cute in the '90s holy crap she probably
still cute I haven't seen her recently
yeah what's she up to I haven't seen her
I mean was so like I said I don't even
know actors if they're still around
because there's so many movies and so
many TV shows it's like for all I know
they could be famous on some TV show
that I don't know about you know what I
mean so it's like I'm never like hey
where'd they go I don't know uh Zan said
I'll have to send blood diamond and
Inception soon oh that would be awesome
you send a man [__] we'll immediately
do it yeah because i' I've seen both of
those um and they're both excellent okay
so and um you know I and I think you
will like them we yeah I'm becoming a
DiCaprio fan yeah see like I said I kind
of feel like a lot of people don't want
to because well we are old enough to
remember like when he first came on the
scene like I said when he came he was in
What's Eating Gilbert Grape he was
actually great in that that was that his
first role couldn't have been I mean he
was pretty young then but yeah like then
he was in Romeo and Juliet and then he
was in Titanic and that just like blew
up and um when Titanic came out I turned
on him I was like I a lot of people did
but I I like I it's an okay movie I
don't love it but it's pretty good I'm
thinking I maybe I should see that one
too but you know what I mean
everybody loves it um but uh Romeo and
Juliet he knocks it out of the park in
Romeo and Juliet but he but you know he
he's a kid actor he does a great job in
it
yeah but there was something about
Titanic coming out and he flooded the
market so much with Titantic that I was
like like everybody sick at [__] face
you know sick yeah but uh no this movie
here may be a believer the scene in this
in shudder Island where he's having the
flashback when he finally has the moment
Moment of clarity where he actually
remembers what happened like with his
wife Dolores like drowning their three
kids and he goes out there and is like
Gathering all their bodies up like in
the thing and he's just like freaking
out that is so good I mean he's like I
was just like
yeah my jaw [__] dropped at that like
it was just really really movie is a
masterpiece kind of reminds me of The
Green Mile too being a perial oh yeah
slightly even though that was the 20s
was it not yeah there but it has that
period this is the50s and um it it's
still it's I think it's those are all
great movies that we mentioned I put it
above Green
Mile uh yeah well just because I look I
love Green Mile and like I said that's a
Stephen King thing we reviewed that not
too long ago but Green Mile I don't know
if I'd necessarily call that a horror
movie it's just weird flick it's you
know it's kind of a fantasy thing um
fantasy drama Adventure
paranormal like I said I think I would
almost maybe call this a horror
movie yeah because I'm saying and you
know if you guys saw that I put up my
history of horror movies thing I
absolutely called Jacob's Ladder a
horror movie and this is kind of
similar you know what I mean because
he's having like all these weird
flashbacks and there's all these really
weird creepy dream
sequences you know yeah um where he is
seeing now here's the thing so he has
all these flashbacks of um DACA like the
limit the the when they liberated it and
he um you know was kind of the first one
to fire the volley of shots against like
all the Nazi guards or whatever when
they did and they and he keeps having
all of these um Visions or memories of
like all the bodies that they found now
didn't they say in the movie that that
had actually happened to him or was he
making that up too I don't know I was
pretty sure that they said cuz he was a
federal Marshall he wasn't making that
up oh no yeah I think he saw no he he
did see a bunch of bodies I think they
did he did find that's what I thought a
concentration camp but they said that he
did not machine gun the guards that that
was that that like that whole scene with
him just like letting that Nazi dude die
like that that Nazi guy that tried to
like shoot himself and like missed and
then he was just laying there dying and
he's like nah [__] you I'm just what's
up Sly good to have you back bro hey
what's up so but see that's the thing
that cool about this movie is that
you're never because it's all subjective
it's all from Teddy's point of view who
is not really who he thinks he is you
are never entirely
sure what's real and what's not even in
the [__] that's really happening you
know what I'm saying like the whole
scene where him and his quote unquote
partner who's played by Mark Ruffalo
Chuck who actually ends up spoiler alert
being his doctor but he's pretending to
be his partner and that whole scene
where they're up on the cliffs cuz he
wants to go to the lighthouse and then
like he thinks that he sees Chuck's body
down in the rocks and he like climbs
down there and he's like oh my God I got
to save him like they took him to the
lighthouse and all this other stuff it's
like did that scene really happen I
don't know that you know what I mean so
it that's kind of what's cool about it
it's like really really ambiguous as
Ruff Ruffalo I only knew that dude from
his role as the Hulk he's been in a
bunch of [__] though which is kind of a
thin ass [__] all that MCU [__] is
pretty [__] thin in this movie he's a
[__]
man I always liked yeah just goes to
show you a lot of these [__] silly
ass actors are good when you give them
the right material you give them yeah
you know you know so yeah and [__]
DiCaprio becoming a fan becoming a fan I
want to see blood diamond Z send me
blood diamond bro when I I want to
review it yeah and that other one you
said when you get a chance Inception
Inception that's another that's another
mind [__] I keep wanting to get you to
watch momento because that's also on
Amazon Prime like I said that's
Christopher Nolan's first one I think I
turned him off it because I said oh it's
in reverse order all the scenes are in
reverse order but it's like it's I don't
I didn't find it particularly hard to
follow I don't think you'll find it
particularly hard to follow if you just
and Guy Pierce is in it if you just
should join the show I'm going to
reiterate if um if you like this movie
if you've seen it before see uh midnight
alley by Gil nightmare alley by been
dring by Gil Toro it's very similar and
just as good another Masterpiece you
could learn from Nightmare alley really
good it's about mind [__] people and
this one is kind of like well like I
said that's kind of like yeah another
thing I don't know I feel like like I
said this movie you could totally
because his delusion right is that his
wife died in a fire he's coming here to
Shutter Island to investigate The
Disappearance of this woman who killed
her three children like like she just
disappeared and she escaped and he's
coming here to investigate that and also
as a sideline the person who lit the
match that caused the apartment fire
that killed his wife is also supposedly
on this island so this is this whole
narrative that he has come up with and
so you know and then he finds out like
as the his investigation goes on that
they're doing all of these Nazi type
experiments on the prisoners like you
know scrambling their brains and trying
to essentially like turn them into
Manchurian candidates is what they're
saying they're trying to make them he
calls them turning them into ghosts but
he's like they're just trying to like
replace their personalities for CIA
purposes you know what I mean so that's
kind of this whole thing that he's come
up with I will note though that this
movie leaves it just ambiguous enough
that he could be right about that I
don't think he is I do think that you
know when the twist happens and they're
like we just are trying to help you get
better by you know we were going along
with your delusion to see if it would
work you know what I mean um I do think
that that's the case but you could read
it the other way too I'd have to see it
over and over again try to analyze it's
just like just like Total Recall with
Arnold Schwarz ner there's alternate
ways of looking at it yeah and I do kind
of like too that like a lot of the
doctor characters like Ben Kingsley it's
like I feel like he usually plays bad
guys yeah so I kind of think that you're
already primed to think that he's up to
some Sinister [__] but I think in the
end and this is my opinion in the end I
think he is exact what he appears to be
that he is a very very compassionate
doctor and he is actually really trying
to help all of these people by trying to
understand them and trying to listen to
them and he's going through this whole
elaborate ruse because he really hopes
that it's going to help Teddy you know
what I mean because if you see too that
there's there's kind of like doctors
because Max von sido's character he
seems not so down with this you know
kind of he's a lot more cautious about
he's like yeah maybe we should be more
compassionate toward but maybe you know
they might be dangerous and blahy blah
and then you have somebody like Ted
lavine's character who is just
absolutely not we should just like
[__] lobotomize them so they're you
know and just like put them in a room
somewhere so they're not in any trouble
so it's almost kind of like a
spectrum but I don't know I I do kind of
feel like it even though they leave it
slightly ambiguous that yeah Leonardo
DiCaprio's or Teddy's delusion that
could be what's really happening and
they're just mind [__] him like they
really were drugging him and they were
really trying to wipe out his identity
and stuff but I don't think that's the
case I think it is the case that the
doctor was actually trying to help him
and then was really bummed out because
he seemed really bummed out like when he
regresses at the end on the surface it
looks like that he was crazy yeah I'd
have to see it I'd have to see it again
maybe more than once but I guarantee you
the writing is is always is in a way
where it's always going to be left open
to interpretation it could be either but
I think that's the I like movies like
that yeah because it inspires like just
endless discussion because nobody's
right yeah you know what I mean really
right so you could just kind of like to
and I like that I like movies that you
can like just have you know a movies if
you just see it one time and you're like
e that was good and you just kind of
forget about it I mean that what not
great you know for a movie to be great
you want to like keep talking about it
the old the old old arold movie [__]
Total Recall I was convinced that uh no
he wasn't cohagan that he was he was the
good guy all
along but uh over over the years when I
Grew Older I realized that was my
emotions talking to me chances are he
just got the trip that he paid for yeah
to become a secret agent and to and to
see the girl that had the read it the
other way too
yeah find the aliens and everything cuz
they predict everything yeah he was
tripping they tell you at the beginning
they tell you the very beginning
everything that's going to happen
everything then that's what happened and
that's probably that's what happened
that's what he paid for that he saved
Mars was the hero and he secr yeah
that's what he paid for cuz they said
you won't be able to tell the difference
right you know but see that's kind of
like the same thing with this
where you know is he really crazy or are
they mind [__] him that's what's
great about these kind of movies that
are set in like insane asylums or like
you know mental health kind of stuff
because it's like you could totally
leave it open where the person is
totally crazy and they just constructed
this whole elaborate Fantasia in their
mind because of their guilt and [__]
like that about what happened really or
could have just planted those memories
like I said they could be drugging him
like he thought they were all kind of
stuff could be happening I'd have to see
it again like I said I don't
think I think that he was actually crazy
and was like duded um and I think like
the the flashback he has at the end like
with his wife drowning the kids and him
shooting her and stuff I think that's
what really happened and he just kind of
made up this whole thing to deal with it
even though the thing about it is that
um
I don't know I I guess it didn't help
that um because they made reference
later that the reason they were thinking
about lobotomizing him because they were
like this is our last ditch effort if
this whole elaborate roleplay thing that
we're doing like doesn't snap him out of
it cuz he had snapped out of it before
but then he went back into it they said
they're like if he doesn't snap out of
this time they're going to just
lobotomize him because he was violent
cuz remember that other uh prisoner
George noise M who got his ass beat and
um he like Teddy had this whole other
fantasy about what that dude had done
but like George Noy was the only guy in
the movie that basically told him the
truth he's like who did all that to you
he's like you did but he didn't remember
it because that wasn't part of his
fantasy you know what I mean so he had
like beaten up um you know other
prisoners and he had apparently beaten
up and he other actually beat up that
other prisoner too like later on in the
movie but um you know he just started
started wailing on him so they were
afraid that they wouldn't be able to
control him because his Tendencies were
so violent because I'm sitting there
thinking well why necessarily would they
have put
somebody in this criminally insane
hospital if he had just I'm not saying
it's cool to like shoot your wife but
she had just murdered their three
children and she basically said she was
very very mentally ill and she basically
told him Set Me
Free and he seemed like he didn't really
want to do it mhm you know what I mean
so I kind of feel like a lot of but see
the thing about it is that after he did
that I guess he just went off the
[__] well he was kind of diluted
before that because he wasn't I mean she
was obviously messed up she burned their
[__] down and he was just like nah n n
you're fine we're just going to move out
to this lake house and everything's
going to be cool and I guess that then
his wife like killing the kids he just
couldn't deal with because I mean he
even says like later on he's just kind
of like I killed them because I should
have done something to help her because
I knew that she wasn't you know that she
was mentally ill and I didn't do
anything to help her I was just kind of
like papering it over and like thinking
everything was going to be okay so he
held himself responsible not only for
killing her but
for not getting her help before she did
what she did so that you know and and
like I said I don't
know even though they do imply as far as
I remember in the movie that he was
actually in the war and that maybe he
was I don't know if he was actually
there like when they liberated daau or
whatever but it's just kind of like I
don't even know if he was like shot the
Germans or like that whole scene with
the guy that the the German guy that
tried to like kill himself and he just
like stood there and watched him die I
don't know if any of that was true um or
or if it if that was just something else
that he was like piling on top of the
guilt that he felt you know what I mean
because it was kind of hard to tell like
what was real and what wasn't because
you were seeing everything subjectively
from his perspective and he was
delusional you know what I mean so
that's what makes this movie so good
because it's just kind of like there's
just so many like interpretations of it
I guess um xan said I love Titanic yeah
man if you uh he didn't have a Blu-ray
of uh Blood Diamond on there uh but if
you find anything you can send it to me
if not we'll just watch uh I'll watch
Blood Diamond probably on Prime yeah we
can find somebody said that um taboo
starring
um um Tom Hardy is probably on Prime I
don't know that oh yeah we should look
that one up then I don't know that movie
yeah um Tammy said Leo was on the TV
show Growing paints holy [__] i' had
forgotten all about that that wasn't
with that was uh Kirt Cameron right the
guy that turned into a weird creationist
later
um yeah Danny said a lot of people still
talk about him in Basketball Diaries
yeah that was a great movie about who
Leonard decaprio that was one of his
early roles yeah okay Danny says this
film and LA Confidential are almost
similar kind of yeah LA Confidential is
another neon Noir I really liked that
one too I think I saw that in the
theater Sebastian said has anyone
mentioned Catch Me If You Can we have
not but I really really do like that
movie actually if you like to catch me
if you can please read the book which is
also called Catch Me If You Can um the
movie's good but the book is a lot
better because the book goes into like a
lot more [__] this was based on a true
story um a guy named Frank abing nail
who I've been wanting to Sho do a show
about for a long time because he was one
of those dudes that he was that guy that
I was talking about who flew planes and
like did surgery and like and didn't you
know what I mean he was just like a yeah
and then like later on he um became like
he started working for the government
like helping them you know what I mean
like catch people that you know did
check fraud and stuff like because he
knew how to do it but just the balls on
this dude I mean it's a fascinating
[__] story and the movie they made it
was um uh Tom Hanks was in it too and
the movie was real good but like I said
the book's a lot better because it goes
into a lot more [__] that he did that
they didn't put in the movie which I
thought was kind of she's looking for
the paper she's like where did it oh I
moved the paper I [__] it up for you
you she like what happened to it yeah
yeah it's
gone she's so disappointed um Tom has
not seen The Departed he has
not if y'all want reviews on this [__]
man send us a Blu-ray it'll put go to
the front of the line yeah if not then
it just just depends on what we watch
yeah cuz sometimes it just kind of
depends like if somebody sends us movies
we'll do them they or if we like if we
remember something like in the context
of talking about another movie it's like
oh yeah we should do that one cuz we
haven't done it cuz there's a zillion
movies we haven't done there's [__] out
and it doesn't have to be new man I just
want it to be like a Blu-ray and it
could be used uh and a lot of times you
know what I mean it's cheaper than a
Super Chat to [__] send it to us so
you know and then we'll we'll do the
show and that helps build up my [__]
catalog I got a [__] whole bunch of
[__] but if not have solid media yeah I
mean other than that it's usually just
the reason we ended up watching this on
Saturday night was just because I was
scrolling through Amazon Prime and I was
like oh I was like I've been wanting to
see that because like I said for some
reason I never got around to it even
though I wanted to see it for a long
time and I was just like I'm kind of in
the mood for that so I asked him about
it I was like do you want to see this or
do you want to see momento because those
were the two that I was in the mood for
I said I kind of want to see like a mind
[__] kind of movie and he wanted to
watch this one so we watch this one yeah
I'm gonna say it again in case you just
joining us if you like this split see
Gil or D Toro's [__] nightmare out
the [__] it it's similar similar
quality hardcore movie you can learn
stuff
from just awesome tale about a dude a
murderer who [__] joins the circus to
become a [__] psychic he's a fake
psychic but he can con anybody and then
he runs into some psychologists or
psychiatrists that are doing the same
thing and they're having a war over this
[__] Rich dude who's a murderer it's
a [__] weird click man really good
really good s I'd kind of like to read
the book actually and see the original
movie that they made back in the day
yeah I think they made the back in the
40s yeah and Geeks are involved yeah and
where Geeks come from yeah it's fcking
[__] weird flick man but it's kind of
a dark Noir movie like this with a lot
of [__] twists and mental
games and [__] kind of it's a kind of
movie where [__] makes you not trust
anybody that everything is a scam you
know because everything in Nightmare
alley is a [__] scam yeah I already
think everything is a scam yeah it's all
scam winter fell forever says the scene
where decaprio remembers what happened
with his kids is absolutely
heartbreaking yeah I was just saying
that a little bit earlier I was just
like that
if anybody thinks Leonardo DiCaprio
isn't a good actor watch that [__]
scene you know what I mean that is a
horrifying [__] he's good man he won me
over in this movie I'm like man [__]
Leonardo Decap was good and I thought he
was great in
[__] Romeo Juliet but he was a kid
actor then yeah yeah he was a kid I
didn't and I did see him in um uh The
Aviator but I thought that movie it was
a good movie but not a great movie I
thought it was a good movie yeah it was
all right it was all right like I liked
it it it was enjoyable it's just like I
kind of like forgot about it yeah it's
forgettable this is a great flip but
this one I'm not going to forget about
this one I want this one on Blu-ray I
kind of like Weir you know I like
weirder movies The Aviator seemed like
one of those big it's really really good
but it's one of those really big crowd
pleasing kind of movies that kind of
just like hits all the Beats of like a
classic Hollywood movie and that's good
like you enjoy it when you watch it but
then it's not super memorable I like
movies like this that have like a little
bit of grit to them that have like a
little bit of weird Ness to them that
have a bit of ambiguity to them so
you're still like talking about him like
trying to figure them out like later on
and I like
how I like how this one is almost like I
mentioned before almost like meta like
the way he shot it was like slightly
slightly artificial so it was almost
trying to clue you in that what you were
seeing wasn't entirely real it was an
enhanced reality yeah so I really liked
the way it was shot in that regard
because it's like every looks just
slightly slightly slightly off-kilter
like slightly hyperreal and that's why
because you're seeing it from his
perspective and he's not entirely
rational you got all kinds of comments
in there suggestions I know well
everybody said okay so um Camp guy said
Tom has got to see The Departed yeah I
agree you probably should what's that
one about um it's like a gangster flick
and who's in it um everybody everybody
Leonardo Caprio Jack
Nicholson oh [__] I didn't know about
that one yeah and it's all right did
that win the
Oscar I thought that won the Oscar that
year I can't the year it came out um
Tammy said taboo is a series it's based
it's on Prime freey and Plex okay so
we'll have to watch a series it's a
series yeah don't want Tom Hardy in it
yet okay how many is in it how many how
many I don't know I guess we'll find out
because I have I have all of those
what's it about well I don't know we'll
find out what's it
about what's going on what
it ate the
goat I can't believe you remember
that that's kind of like my go to like
whatever and that's going back along
when did the first Jurassic Park come
out 1993 90s me and my friend Jen whose
name is also Jen we saw Jurassic Park in
the theater when it first came out and
that it was packed obviously so we saw
it and right behind us there was this
old old man and his wife and I guess the
old guy was maybe dead F or I don't
really know but like his wife kept like
mumbling to him like what was going on
in the cuz he would always like whatever
was going on the mov who's this now
what's happening and then it's a but he
kept like commenting on like what so
when they put the goat out and the
dinosaur ate it he goes very like very
loudly it ate the
goat and I was just kind of like yes yes
sir thank you we are all watching the
same movie that you're watching thank
you very much for providing the running
commentary but you know sometimes the
old man wants to be the
wants to be the center of it ain't the
goat so now like every time so now every
time somebody says like something that's
like really obviously happening in the
movie I always go it ain't the goat like
in an old man's voice cuz that's I still
remember that this many because [__] man
that was what 30 years ago now or
something like that but I still remember
it like it was [__] yesterday because
it was just like so [__] funny it's
like old people at Movies man yeah holy
crap they're always like talking but
it's like yeah so it's always cuz Tom
does that sometimes too and I like I
make fun he didn't he didn't say it but
he'll be like well who is this what
happened what happened what's going on
yeah yeah
yeah is this that person that did that
and I was just like no just watch it I
was just like just watch it yes I do it
in the house though not in the movie
theater yeah you don't do it in the
movie theater yeah every now and then he
does it the movie theater but he'll
whisper at least but he does it in the
houseold like who was this yeah who's
that it's like it just reminds me of
that it's like funny um but yeah so
let's see um people saying that yeah
nightmare alley was [__] awesome
Tammy saw both of them I love that movie
yeah I want to see The Originals yeah
yeah yeah Zan said The Departed is a top
five gangster movie of all time man I
haven't seen it yeah I mean yeah like
send that [__] to me man anybody wants
to send us this [__] we'll we'll talk
about it Zan said that they is sending
the Departed and Inception is that he oh
that's awesome okay awesome all right if
you guys want to send us something just
contact CU you haven't seen either one
of those you can contact Jen either here
on on knows what our address YouTu I'm
talking about other people he knows
where we live you can contact Jen on
Instagram Facebook or YouTube 13 o'clock
podcast or Jennifer Ashford yeah she
give Jenny Ashford she'll give you the
uh the address you can send that [__]
here through Amazon yeah either on the
13 podcast page or my personal page and
then um which is now Jenny Ashford Ross
we'll we'll review it it'll go to the
front of the line yeah somebody send us
we just review it yeah usually in a
couple
days Winterfell forever said I think the
performances in The Departed are way
better than the plot itself the premise
is great but the execution is kind of
all over the place it has some plot
holes and it's unnecessarily
complicated yeah I don't yeah I don't
know I I guess I see what you're saying
though yeah C gu said The Departed won
best picture are Oscar and I think maybe
score say he won for director but not
sure yeah I thought it was at least
nominated but I don't usually watch the
Oscars and I usually forget to
um yeah Tammy said that show taboo is
about Tom Hardy being sexy as hell
that's really all you need okay we had
to see that this back arch com into play
cuz I I'm a I'm a student of the back
arch I'm trying I got to see how he did
that I'll [__] make all kinds of
money on
[__] on on [__] fans Ley he's got
like a [__] pro track I don't have't
put a up on fans Ley yet I'm gonna put
some [__] up on fley I can't believe you
haven't put anything up there long I
[__] got a new a long time ago Roman
chair in where I'm [__] doing Roman
Chair exercises [__] get some [__]
taper more taper to the waist on the
back that way you don't have two butts
you only got one yeah butt here and
another butt try to get rid of all that
[__] [__] the extra butt the extra butt
yeah just trying to bring that [__] in
see [__] daddy porn Tom's trying to
be all foxy it's your I'm not trying I
was going to say you don't got to try
you SE it in my you're you're just natur
1% for
[__] you're naturally foxy he didn't
have it ain't natural none of this
shit's all super you know what I mean
though yeah I mean you don't have to try
nothing all shit's all
Supernatural I'm a Sith Lord and I'm
[__] biologically enhanced yeah
yeah yeah straw dog 78 said in taboo Tom
Hardy plays a man that decides to go up
against the British East India Company
oh that sounds good already yeah and
Tammy said it's only eight episodes
believe me you were going to wish there
was more okay okay that does s good
actually what year are we talking when
did this happen I I don't know okay I
mean I guess it's fairly recent like I
said there's too much [__] for me to
keep track of man it's like it's hard
for me to just keep track of the horror
movies and then like all the other [__]
that I want to see like dramas and
Mysteries and thrillers and all that
kind of stuff it's like it's too much I
don't have time I wish I had time but I
don't um Winterfell forever said talking
about horror very good horror series is
the terror yeah we saw that about an
actual English Expedition close to the
North Pole
Circa 1850 is very good yeah I liked
that a lot it's actually based on The
Dan Simmons novel although it's also
based on a true thing yeah I thought the
quality was very good of that movie but
I also thought that the the I thought
the story was kind of dry and boring a
little bit I kind you know what if
they're gonna do a Dan Simmons novel I
really wish they'd make a series out of
drood God I love that [__] book cuz
it took a long time for things to happen
in that um it probably would that that
that is a series that would have made a
better book well it was a book it was
was a book yeah yeah it was a novel like
it's Dan Simmons and I love Dan yeah and
then uh director was uh dude from Blade
Runner his name um the new Blade Runner
no old Blade Runner oh okay what was his
name who Ridley Scott Ridley Scott yeah
Ridley Scott did that and Ridley
Scott he's good when he's he's real good
when he's sober okay that dude drinks
too much it just um he's I think he's
better with five when they don't [__]
butcher his work Prometheus would have
been [__] great had they not chopped
that [__]
up because they didn't want to [__]
talk about space Jesus you know [__]
Jes yeah space Jesus that Jesus was
[__] an alien plant that would been a
great horror [__] angle well yeah and
they didn't want to even mention Jesus
[__] these [__] the original
promethus script was [__]
great uh let's see hold on um Danny says
what's Wednesday's show going to be oh I
told you guys before but um our listener
mut sent us two books about this one
particular case this happened in the
1970s and it happened in Minnesota like
at this really famous like mansion that
you can do tours there's like a um like
a very brutal murder that took place
there so it's called like the Glen Sheen
murders so that's what we're going to be
talking about cuz I've been reading
these two books cuz we thought well he
sent us these books so I'm going to do a
show about that that's we're going to do
show about but it's a it's a good case
I've been watching like some
documentaries about it stuff like that
uh Zan said both movies should be there
on Saturday Okay um I'm going to have to
rewatch Inception yeah I really need to
I saw it before okay but there's a lot
to talk about with that because that's
another kind of mind [__] okay you
going to get two reviews back to back I
mean we could either do a double feature
or we could do one one and then another
and then another one yeah each one's
going to get a full review yeah if you
can buy multiple movies you don't we
don't cheap out you're going to get full
review yeah I would think yeah yeah
Danny says Prometheus is great the
sequel was complete poopy oh
yeah it wasn't terrible but it wasn't
well you knew that they bastardized the
original so it had to go down this
[__] weird way now they're working on
alien Romulus which is supposed to be
something happening in between alien and
Aliens like one and two which is they
say it's going to be pretty good but I
don't believe anything until I see it um
there can't you can't tell any more
stories about
Xenomorphs I mean Alien versus Predator
I thought was a good angle that
but the [__] Engineers was a great
angle they should have just gone down
that way I because I know what the
original script
said bunch of Immortals basically that
were seeding the seeding the [__]
Galaxy with humanoid
life because they had lost the ability
to Pro proc
create well what they're talking about
is they're talking about [__] all the
damn religious Mythos that we have giant
people from the Stars creating life sons
of God type of deal
angels anunaki that was a [__] great
angle and they [__] it up and I I'm
not GNA blame Ridley Ridley for that he
that was a great idea it's just the
studios the studios wanted an alien
movie with Xenomorphs and [__] they told
that story already
yeah you know well the thing about it
though is that a lot of times I can you
know I don't want to defend Studio heads
because a lot of times their heads are
up their asses and they don't really
know anything but sometimes too they're
like okay well you can just do what you
want and then the director does like
some crazy [__] and then audiences are
like nah bro and they like they won't go
see it and then it's like a failure so I
can see why they're cautious and they're
like well we just want to go with
something that has been successful in
the past
yeah like they're you know they're very
conservative in that regard they don't
really want to do anything weird or
anything new or anything like that
because they're afraid that nobody's
going to go see it because it's like an
untested premise I get that Prometheus
looked great the problem with Prometheus
why people didn't like it because it
didn't make any goddamn sense and it
didn't make any sense because the studio
cut it to Pieces it would have been much
better had they just let it [__] ride
with the script that he had it made
perfect
sense but people wanted to like you know
and it didn't have anything to do with
the [__] ship that they found that
had the original eggs that was on
another planet in that same system but
they were going to get to that
evidently yeah well what are you gonna
do yeah Zach just got here hey guys up I
just got back just now Zach I mentioned
you [__] just got back from a hookup
okay well it wasn't you cuz you were
here it could have been me I'm I don't a
hook up with y'all gays
like except when that one song is on
just when that yeah with [__] gav
Friday comes on and Angel starts playing
Z
alls all bets are off there's the bubble
bath bubble bath [__] Vegas the pink
champ top of the damn [__] Penthouse
of a Vegas [__] hotela and [__] [__]
rotating whole [__] silver platter
platters of ludes and cocaine and all
kinds of [__] and condoms wow no [__]
condoms me me and me and Zach don't need
no [__] C Jenny there with the
[__] camera bubble bath and [__]
going it's a gay Paradise it better be a
heart-shaped bathtub that's gay Paradise
that kind of paradise could never happen
between het heterosexuals it's not
subversive enough yeah it's got to be
homosexual yeah this [__] shit's
Dirty Man perverted [__] that's what
makes it so hot ain't that right
Zach everybody likes [__] that's a
little bit yeah that [__] [__] yeah what
the [__] man you know how I know how you
are you like well my [__] me and J
were throwing down before this [__]
show I was tearing it up up man yeah
yeah yeah and I was so [__] tired
afterwards I I got and I took a nap did
you really you [__] sucked my soul
out well I guess it was a good thing
that I like went in there like a couple
hours for the show started you what now
that I went in there a couple hours
before the show started so you actually
had time to yeah
recover yeah I was like okay yeah yeah
yeah cuz you were just like I got to get
some sleep he was like worn out I well
this [__] went down right here man right
behind us
it didn't happen me in bed those [__]
was
spontaneous she came in the room [__]
I was sitting there [__] halfway
dozed up she goes let's go [__] I was
like okay yeah I'm I'm in move for that
yeah see asking you shall receive sure I
know I like it [__] I like that [__]
just spontaneous you know yeah like all
right yeah yeah he just came right away
he's like all right yeah I I could do
that you didn't understand the power
that you had
oh my
God all right so we've got we've
wandered very far a field from the movie
but you know yeah this is a great flick
totally endorsed by [__] Tom Ross and
I'm not [__] and Tom's super picky
you know if he likes something then you
know it's got to be real I was 10
minutes into this movie going this movie
is [__] great yeah he really got in
like way into it like I said he was like
I got good taste immediately like got
his attention he put the he turned off
the tablet and put the tablet down which
is this serious I got to watch this
that's a very serious cuz like I said if
he's not into something he'd just be
like I no quality when I see it I no
quality and no quality storytelling and
good acting I'm a trained actor so I
know I'm go the oh they're they're
they're not [__] around here I didn't
know it was Martin Scorsese yeah it
makes more sense now it's I feel like
it's a movie of his that nobody I'm not
saying nobody talks about it but a lot
of people don't talk about it like it's
almost kind of one of his quote unquote
forgotten ones even though it made like
all the money it made a [__] t money
what like $250 million or something it
made a lot of money I didn't know I
never heard of this yeah like I said I
kept hearing about it but for and I kept
like oh yeah I got to see that because
it's kind of like a horror movie and
it's just like I just never got around
to it because I was like oh I want to
see Martin scores he do a horror movie
that's awesome but I just never got
around to it but then like Saturday
night I saw it on Amazon Prime and I was
just like oh I'm totally in the mood for
that right now let's watch that s's
going on about [__] he's a great
actor of his generation I guess he is MH
I don't know enough about DiCaprio but
yeah I guess he is I want to see more of
his
[__] was out of the DiCaprio loop I
don't think I've ever seen him in a bad
movie now that I'm thinking about it I'd
have to go back and check I know one
thing that old dude he's younger than me
I think he's late 40s right now maybe
very early 50 prob and um he's got he's
always with some [__] hottie man who
was like [__] 22
23 please tell me he's like a cool
person he got to be is it going is it
going to come out later that he's like
some kind of [__] up like I don't know
probably not he's probably pretty cool
maybe he's probably pretty cool I mean I
heard anything bad about him but that I
don't really like keep up with all that
stuff so it it's possible he was also if
I remember correctly he was said he's in
his 50s so he's our age so okay so he's
my age I thought he was younger than me
um wasn't he also in
um uh [__] what was his name of that
once upon a time in Hollywood yeah yeah
he did a great job he's [__] great in
that love I forgot about that I own that
movie that I own that movie one of the
best Tarantino flicks yeah oh yeah yeah
EAS oh yeah and it was like it was so
long and it was like a hangout movie but
I didn't even I didn't give a [__] I was
just like vibing with it I was like man
this is a [__] blast I really I
forgot about that flick he does I really
like that movie [__] uh DiCaprio does
a [__] outstanding job as an actor in
that one [__] real good yeah yeah he
plays a Western actor
yeah yeah yeah he's great in that [__]
yeah he gets involved in the [__]
Massa
family yeah [__] yeah it's a great
flick I mean that's just everybody in
that is so good I love that movie so
much yeah yeah we own that actually M we
saw that in the theater saw in the
theater twice twice actually and then
the first thing I did is when when it
was available on Blu-ray I [__]
ordered it's excellent I really really
like I think I I think it's a steelbook
Edition I got yeah I I think I bought it
for you yeah so I got to for your
birthday or Christmas or something I got
to have that one yeah Tam says Leo is 49
49 okay he's younger than me so couple
years younger than I am yeah he's five
years younger than me okay oh yeah yeah
and Zan said he seems pretty private
he's not in the media a lot well that's
a that's a
plus that's always a plus he staying
single and he's [__] hanging out with
them young chicks but I understand it I
understand it he can yeah he can yeah I
mean like I said he's good looking guy
as long as everyone's consenting and
nothing comes out like some Epstein [__]
like you know what I mean no standing is
he likes him around
25 well I mean I guess he can get it
yeah and like I said that's legal so
yeah what are you gonna do yeah what are
you gonna do uh yeah they're talking
about he was in The Great Gatsby too
yeah um I didn't see yeah I didn't see
that version I've read the book
obviously and I've seen some other
versions of the movie but um I didn't
see the Leonardo decaprio version I did
it's weird because it seemed like it
almost like nobody really talks about it
and so I don't even know if it was good
or I like I always liked that book I
read it in school
but um Zach says doesn't this movie have
that really sad violin song in it that's
in every movie when I have a sad scene I
don't know this movie actually I'm
pretty sure that this was all this was
all a classical score if I remember
correctly they used a lot of mostly
classical music in this and there's like
um gustaff mer and uh a bunch of other
pieces in it but I think it was all
classical so I don't know if there was
any score that was specifically for this
movie um yeah the Howard Hugh yeah we
were talking about that before The
Aviator which I remember really liking
but I only saw it once and I I remember
liking it a lot but I don't really
remember a lot about it you know what I
mean like I was like oh that was good
but it didn't really stick with
me Danny says uh eBay has blood diamond
for 719 free shipping s it Larter next
time
dude well like I said we have pretty
much all all the streaming services not
all of them but a lot of them um so we
can usually find most of the movies but
Tom does like to own movies he really
likes he likes to have them like a
physical copy so when he saw this
Saturday he was just like yeah I'm going
to buy that so I was happy because like
I said I told
him sometimes it's I usually let him
pick you know what I mean because I'm
just kind of like cuz I'll watch
whatever I don't I'm not really all that
picky I don't know well that's not true
but it's you know what I mean I'll watch
pretty much anything I'll be like ah
that was all right but I was kind of in
the mood for either this movie cuz I
hadn't seen it or momento which I have
seen a couple of times I actually saw
that in the theater when it came out but
I wanted Tom to see it because he really
likes Christopher Nolan and he had never
seen it so I was like okay well I was
like which one do you want to watch um
you know because then you can't complain
if I if I pick something and he doesn't
like it then he's going to [__] at me I
don't [__] I don't [__] I just kind of
check but then I'll but then I'll feel
bad I kind of just check out I'm like so
I was very happy like when we first
started watching this like and he put
the tablet down and like just sat there
and watched it and I was like oh all
right he's liking this movie he's liking
this movie I got good taste I can tell
when the good movies come it's I can
never tell I've told you before it's
like it's easy to tell at home when
we're watching something at home because
like I said if you don't I know if you
don't like something because you just
pick your tablet back up and check out
of it when we're in the theater I can't
ever tell because you just kind of sit
there and look at it I mean unless you
fall asleep or something because you've
done that a couple times but falling
asleep in movies I liked that's true
though too sometimes they they'll L me
to sleep the one that really surprised
her is that when she took me to see um
the art of self-defense art of
self-defense one of my favorite movies I
thought you would hate it one of my
favorite movies CU I I loved it I
watched it I was like oh my God this is
like cuz that's exactly my sense of
humor watch that [__] over and over
again cuz I love dark comedy there's so
much truth in it about Warrior Cults all
right I just the whole time I was
watching I'm like oh my God going to
hate I'm like this is not comedy this is
a do umentary yeah this is [__] count
Dante and the [__] you know well yeah
it's based on this about this is about
count Dante and the [__] what was the
name of this [__] little uh the the
black dragon black dragon fighting
Society yeah that was the kind of [__]
they were doing so I immediately you
know like yeah okay this is it this is
real yeah it was
funny but no that's that's funny like in
a dark kind of way which like I said I
was kind of into that cuz like it was
almost exactly my sense of Cam was
[__] hilarious they're using martial
arts but there's also some [__] kind
of spill over into [__] military
units with like airborne and Rangers and
[__] like that they're kind of like that
too which is insane insane Warrior Cults
you know yeah but it's funny it's it's
it's ripe for black comedy that that
whole idea and the dude that [__]
wrote that [__] was soy as [__] but no I
I I agreed with him yeah I understand I
understand his Viewpoint his I I was
seeing in a way I was seeing my world
through his Viewpoint and and kind of
agreeing with him yeah you know but you
know he was he was seen as an observer
and I was seeing it as a participant
right yeah that's what it's
like Zach says you know uh you wouldn't
think scorsese's really Jagged and
energetic style would work for a horror
movie but I guess it
does yeah um like I said I kind of feel
like this is almost like a I don't know
if I'd call it an outlier in scor's um
you know
film uh catalog but it's definitely a
different thing but like I said I kind
of like the way he just made it I'm
going to make it like an old school Noir
movie like it has this real overwrought
score and it's just like has this kind
of artifice to it and it's just like I
like that he just went balls deep and
just made it like a movie from back then
I think maybe some critics didn't get
that that that's what he was doing but
cuz they were like oh it's just it's too
much it's like over the top or whatever
but it's just like I'm not at all I
didn't think it was like that at all I
think if you watch it through the lens
of like a 40s Noir movie like it makes
total sense he's homaging that but and
and it is like creepy it's scary and I
really liked all the imagery and stuff
so yeah it totally worked I think sander
says I'm going to love what movie where
is it down at the bottom said
okay Tom's going to love The Departed
yeah I I always kind of thought he
probably would Jack Nicholson Mark
Wahlberg Matt Damon and Leonardo
decaprio it's amazing yeah wallberg yeah
Mark wallberg is in [__] that's
another one of my favorite movies man
he's another guy that you wouldn't think
would be yeah that all that good cuz he
was just like you know he was Marky Mark
and the Funky bun Bunch he's [__]
great man [__] that Florida movie that I
saw but he was at pain again pain again
but I mean the first time I saw him and
it's cuz he was in movies before that
but like I saw him in Boogie Nights and
he was [__] great in that like he's
really good now I he doesn't have much
range as an actor I will say that but
they cast him right though but when they
cast him as someone that's a little bit
someone who's kind of like not all that
bright and like out of their depth he's
great at that kind of role yeah you know
what I mean which like I said that's you
know if y all haven't seen Pain and Gain
see it it's [__] got The Rock in it
Mark Wahlberg it's got a it's got a
Allstar cast and it's a Florida it's a
Florida true crime story about some [__]
that really happened here it's on the
part it's on par with the black dragon
fighting Society man [__] some dudes
dressed up like ninjas [__] capturing
people to holding Ransom hilarious to a
true story it's true story and it's not
that exaggerated the movie isn't and the
dude came out of a gym he was a fitness
instructor played by Mark wber it's [__]
in a high-end [__] gym down in Miami
and they dressed up as ninjas to do
their [__] crimes and when people
told the police yeah just no the police
didn't believe them which is in a way
they did the [__] cuz they were dumb as
[__] but it's also but it was also
genius yeah it was so dumb that it kind
of came around and believe that no they
weren't dressed as yeah they were ninjas
we got attacked by
ninjas sometimes you can do [__] that's
like so stupid that it's almost like
genius yeah yeah they dressed up like
ninjas and Commandos on another one when
they [__] attacked the dude's [__]
palacial [__] waterfront home yeah
it's just [__] it's a [__] up story
yeah Danny says uh we should do momento
and also we should do the others oh I've
been wanting to do the others for a
really long time that's a good movie
yeah that's one of my favorite ghost
stories ever look we've been we've been
on we've been online for a while um
let's go ahead and wrap it up 15 minutes
well wait Winterfell forever says how
about the Three Musketeers decaprio is
awful in it by the way horrendous movie
everybody is in it for the check I don't
remember if I ever saw that saw yeah I
never saw I think I saw clips of it it
did look kind of bad yeah I just never
bothered never even heard of it yeah
I've I saw I remember seeing like
trailers and [__] for it and I think
I've seen Clips but I didn't like watch
it all the way through um and Danny also
says American Ultra is Jesse Eisenberg
at his best he was the guy that was in
art of self-defense he was also in
Zombie Land which also I like Eisenberg
I really respect his his and he was in
vivarium viari [__] love viarum hey
if there's any Eisenberg Flex yall want
me to see send it to me I like e ber you
should see the Facebook movie and his
girlfriend that was with him in those
two movies was [__] also really good
I think that's his girlfriend they're
always working together um yeah yeah
imagene Poots yeah yeah she did a
[__] great job in very I like her
she's she's in a lot of yeah she's
really good she SE a lot of good stuff
uh Zach says I think you guys would love
killers of the flower Moon that's the
newest Martin scores movie uh it's kind
of a horror movie too yeah I kept seeing
the trailers it does look good um Danny
says The Departed is definitely not
accurate at all Wy buer went out a way
more horrific way unlike the movie yeah
but you know we'll get into it we should
probably do a show about Wy buer one of
these days there's a Whitey Bulger movie
with uh yeah I know with what's his name
is in
it I think there's more than one if I
remember incorrectly one the dude you
know the [__] dude the dude that
played [__] the pirate movie oh [__]
what's his name who Johnny de Johnny
Depp Johnny Depp did a buer movie The
Pirate Movie the pirate I knew what you
were talking about I saw Johnny buer and
his men wa B yeah Whitey buer when I
lived in Winter Hill up in Boston I saw
they were unloading some files from a an
abandoned candy store that they were
using that was a weird that was a weird
night it was coming back from the goth
club they had the whole [__] they had
security out and everything and [__]
guys [__] standing
around middle of the [__] night they
were bringing [__] dollies of [__]
file cabinets out loading them in the
back of a truck
right top
[__] um Winter Hill in
uh yeah Winter Hill that's
[__] I saw them I didn't I but I
didn't know who wider buer was yeah I
didn't know who they were but I saw
those guys yeah I didn't know that they
were part of the Winter Hill Gang I
didn't know there was a winter Hill Gang
I just said these dudes are gagsters
they had taken over the whole [__]
Street there's about 15 of
them and they just looked like [__]
corny ass dudes in [__]
suits in the middle of the night [__]
loading [__] up in the back of truck
smiling at me I was coming as I was
coming [__] walked in my apartment
it's like hey don't kill me I didn't see
anything I was like I was looking around
like what the [__] is this they're
looking at you know what this is I said
no I don't know what this is that was
kind of you know what are you guys doing
he's grinning one dude they had on out
on security he was in his 30s it wasn't
buer but buer must have been unloading
the [__] out of the candy shop it's not
there anymore I checked on Google Earth
I
looked down his yeah said that departed
is Loosely based on Whitey buer it's
actually a remake of a Hong Kong movie
right um Danny says Johnny buer is a
good porn name it is yeah it's
buling oh and winter f for I had
forgotten about this scors sayi also
made Kate fear like yeah he did a remake
of Kate fear yeah great film I like it
uh it is over the top perhaps but also
could be seen as a horror yeah it's
classified as a thriller but I would
probably call that and actually I
mentioned it in my horror video that I
just put up the other day like one great
flicks are the 80s yeah yeah yeah
there's just there's a lot of crossover
between horror and Thriller I know
people like to argue about it but you
know because people will say like
Silence of the Lambs isn't a horror
movie [__] that it totally is a horror
movie sorry and I'm pretty sure cap fear
is too I would call it a horror movie
all right so we are gonna wrap this up
uh go get something to eat yeah and uh I
got some chili made do like we do yeah
he made some chili with stuff from the
garden yeah what we were drinking was
from the garden was passion fruit I got
from the Gard yeah we I told him I was
like we got Farm a table we backyard to
table cocktails passion fruit and rum
yeah and I'm I'm we we didn't we didn't
make the rum obviously we bought that at
the liquor store but but the passion
fruit yeah they grew out back yeah uh
but yeah so we're going to wrap it up
for this evening so thank you all for
dropping by uh as I said on Wednesday's
show we're going to be talking about the
Glenn Sheen murders which happened back
in 1977 uh thanks again to mut for
sending us the books about it because
I'm working my through them at the
moment so I can take some more notes and
stuff and uh yeah so that should be good
we'll see you guys again on Wednesday
night good night